one day Matt is riding his skateboard
when he crashes and falls hitting his
head Matt's brain collides with his
skull stretching and tearing some of his
brain tissue Matt has sustained a
concussion concussions are also called
mild traumatic brain injuries you might
be wondering how do these types of
injuries occur normally your brain is
suspended in a cushioning liquid called
cerebral spinal fluid
this fluid allows your brain to stay put
even as your body moves but the high
force impacts associated with a
concussion overwhelm the protection
provided by this special fluid think
about the brain as a very fast computer
that runs your body just like computers
the brain needs a well controlled and
stable environment the blood-brain
barrier creates and maintains this
environment the blood-brain barrier is
made up of blood vessels surrounded by
astrocytes and neurons this barrier is
the brain's gatekeeper and controls what
gets into or comes out of the brain to
ensure that brain cells stay happy it
also provides essential nutrients to all
brain cells when a concussion occurs
some neurons and astrocytes get
stretched and twisted most importantly
some blood vessels brake allowing
molecules that aren't supposed to be in
the brain to get inside these molecules
upset neurons and astrocytes the cells
ask for help from the rest of the body
by sending out chemical distress signals
called biomarkers researchers use
specialized lab equipment to measure
biomarkers in patients blood or saliva -
such blood biomarkers have recently been
approved by the FDA for clinical use and
hopefully doctors will be able to use
these biomarkers to diagnose concussions
however until this new blood test is
readily available doctors still need to
make a diagnosis by examining patients
and asking them as well as their family
and friends
a long list of questions about the
patient's physical cognitive and
behavioral symptoms now we know what
happens inside your brain but what does
this mean for Matt Matt's brain needs
complete rest
meaning no TV no computer time and no
strenuous activity even though he may
not be able to see the harm done to his
brain like he could with a broken arm
brain injuries are serious medical
conditions what started out as a
concussion could become a larger problem
later in life if Matt doesn't take the
appropriate time to recover
[Music]